those that are it doesn't B them from
being treated as victims by the
prosecution by the case we have an open
criminal investigation I am absolutely
enly sure I'll be found innocent I know
the case better than you I know it
intimately and you don't I have seen all
the criminal files and that evidence
against me and you haven't I know the
truth of what happens and you don't and
I'm telling you absolutely not really
I've never hurt anybody that the case
that's been put against me is completely
unly fabricated and I'm never going to
be found guilty of anything and it's
very difficult for me to answer your
in-depth questions we're sitting here
inside of the territory of Romania I am
beholden to the Romanian legal system
and I'm not going to incriminate myself
because you're trying to PR me you are
wrong and we're going to have to accept
that for now and ask